very disturbing report out from the US
military the Army the Navy and the Air
Force all missed their
2023 recruitment goals they missed their
recruitment goals by combined 41,000
Personnel it's not good the annual
defense authorization bill passed by
Congress this year stated that active
duty troops will drop to little under
1.3 million in fiscal year 2024 that's
down by 64,000 troops over the the past
3 years that gives the US military its
smallest Force since 1940 while we are
on the brink of World War I in two
different places in Eastern Europe well
three places actually Eastern Europe the
holy land and potentially in in
Taiwan what does this mean for the US
military it's even worse than just not
recruiting new people the people who
have already been recruited are now
taking to Tik Tok a Chinese platform to
complain about how much they hate the
army
Army okay this guy says cons of being in
the Army part one no
privacy the pay
sucks uh bad food disrespectful
leadership No
Sleep these are top five reasons of why
you shouldn't join the military reason
number one is pay we do not get paid
enough for what we do I'm not here to
say that we get paid pennies I'm just
saying that we don't get paid enough to
perform the mission that is tasked to us
reason number two family you won't see
your family often you might see them on
holidays and and that that's about it I
can elaborate reason number three
schooling now I know you're like whoo
that was a benefit but it's requirements
you have to meet first to be able to get
to that schooling so if you're thinking
about joining because of schooling just
go to school reason number four if
you're a parent now if you join single
and get married and then have kids
that's one thing but if you're already
having a channel you're thinking about
joining don't you got to think about it
boot camp is between 6 to 8 weeks after
boot cam you go to school that's between
10 days to a year after that you go to
deployment that's between 8 months to 9
months think about how much time you
miss with your child reason number five
you do not have 100% say on what you
want to
do and he spelled depression this is a
lady in the Army this m i l i t a r y
whining about that the thing about these
complaints that all of these people are
making is they're all totally
correct I know there are going to be
conservatives out there who are
attacking these guys who say how dare
you where's your patriotism what did you
sign up for this crazy that's not what
the military is like no that is what the
mil I've never served in the military
I'm very grateful to everyone who has I
have a lot of family members who've
served in the military and what these
guys are saying it's absolutely
correct and the problem the reason that
this is coming out now that people the
reason people are complaining about this
the people that the reason that the
military is having a hard time
recruiting people is because the top
brass the military leadership have taken
away all of the incentives to actually
sign up for the military so now what new
recruits are looking at is just all the
list of negatives that have always
existed right now head on over to
expressvpn.com
Michels show have you noticed that big
tech companies today are masquerading as
privacy companies just fix your privacy
settings turn off app tracking and
you're all good yeah right are we
supposed to believe that the big bad
Tech wolf has now turned into our sweet
little Grandma I don't think so big Tech
feeds on your information by collecting
and selling off your data they can't
stop themselves from looking at what you
do online to protect myself against big
Tech's prying eyes I trust expressvpn
when you use expressvpn on your computer
or your phone you are hiding your unique
IP address websites cannot use that
address to find out your real location
or track what you do online on top of
that expressvpn encrypts and reroutes
100% of your online activity so your ey
ISP Wi-Fi admin and hackers cannot see
it best part though is how easy it is to
use it just takes one click to protect
all your devices one expressvpn
subscription covers up to five devices
at the same time so you can protect your
entire family too today is the day get
the VPN that I trust to protect my
online privacy that is expressvpn.com
michelow get three extra months for free
that is
expressvpn.com m a l can w l h w
expressvpn.com
Michel no show to learn more serving in
the military is very very difficult the
pay is bad you don't get to sleep people
yell at you all the time you have to do
a very dangerous job you don't get to
see your family there are not a ton of
benefits that go along with it so the
the reason you do it the reason that one
enlists in the military is out of a
sense of patriotism because you love
your country it's out of a sense of
Honor the notion that it is an honorable
thing to defend your country and it is
dishonorable in a time of crisis in a
time of War to say dodge the draft why
else do you join the military well
there's some fringe benefits uh in part
the respect that you will receive for
the rest of your life people every time
they see you and they find out you serve
they'll say thank you for your
service in part because of the fringe
benefits like schooling GI Bill sends
you to school that's great great way to
pay for
School in part well I don't know I guess
that's about it and the problem right
now is our top brass at the Pentagon and
our entire Society our whole culture
have knocked all of those reasons down
now mock those reasons hold them in
contempt they say patriotism is a joke
this is an evil country founded by
slavers for no other reason than to
exploit poor oppressed minorities it's
an evil evil place we continue to
perpetuate Evil all around the world if
you serve your country not only are you
not honorable but you're actually
dishonorable because this place is
terrible that's the first one the second
one what about that what about the the
notion of Honor that it's it's actually
good to go serve your forget about the
country for a second it's just good for
you to go serve we don't have a culture
of service anymore and that's a problem
largely driven by the left by the right
too because the right has adopted a
greed is good mentality in recent
decades and it said that all that really
matters is going out and getting yours
I'm going to go out there make my money
do what's good for me hook up with the
girls I want to hook up with live my
life forget about other people virtue of
selfishness let's go baby let's read our
IR Rand and then go out there and get
ours that's been a I think that is
ebbing on the right I think that view is
certainly on its way out but that was a
that was a big view on the
right certainly in the
1980s 90s
2000s okay what about the the
the respect you'll get from other people
look you're a veteran you know well
thank you for your service sir what are
you talking about since Vietnam we treat
our veterans terribly some people still
support the troops a lot of people don't
they don't get decent care from the VA
when they get here it's they there have
been efforts to reform the VA it hasn't
gone very well since since Vietnam
Troops have been spit on they've been
called Baby rapers child Killers all
sorts of terrible
things uh where's the where's the honor
that you get just the nice you don't I I
presumably one does not serve strictly
for the social honor that that will
confer but that's nice that's a nice
little perk isn't it well that's gone
too so much for that okay final one what
about the GI bill you get to go to
school well the schools are worthless
now they still matter to some degree as
a credentialing Institution for some
jobs you still need to check that box
but we all know that the schools have
been totally hollowed out from within
the schools Focus much less on good
scholarship than they do on the latest
Dei initiative with the 10,000 person
Army of of Deputy assistant Deputy deans
of diversity inclusion and Equity whose
entire job it is to make straight white
guys feel terrible about themselves okay
and to talk about how evil the Army is
and how terrible America is and how we
all need to feel awful for the sins of
our country so what's the point oh and
by the way the Democrats are going to
pay for your school anyway eventually
eventually Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders are going to get their way and
they're going to pay for your school
Bernie's actually a little better on
that issue than than Elizabeth Warren is
Elizabeth Warren she's going to get her
way they're going to they're going to
slowly start paying for more and more
college so the GI bill is not even an
inducement anymore so why would you
join at that point when all of the good
reasons to sign up for the military are
gone all you're left with is crappy pay
you don't see your family you don't
sleep you get screamed at and you have a
very dangerous
job okay don't be surprised when when
the top
brass is is turning red in the face
screaming before Congress talking about
how important it is for the troops to to
learn about the sources of white rage
and critical race Theory and Dei
ideology how important that is for
military Readiness don't be surprised
when no one wants to join I wouldn't
want to join either man what a great
clip that was now hey hold up ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nolles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time